[Musique]
les vrais acteurs moi je trouve ça con
je les méprise c'est vrai vous leur dit
de pleurer il pleure le dit de rire vous
leur dit de March à C Pat de le fond je
trouve ça grotesque Louis Garel dans la
peau de Jean-Luc Godard monstre du
cinéma français un biopic attendu sur la
Croisette en compétition officielle au
Festival de Cannes il fait partie des 14
films soutenus par la Région
Île-de-France et c'est même l'aide la
plus importante 445000 €. l'île-de-
France fait aussi la part belle au
documentaire pas moins de 7 financé en
2016 dont celui de Raymond de pardon 12
jours traite des personnes hospitalisées
en psychiatrie il est présenté à CAN en
sélection officielle l'an dernier la
région a dédié un budget de 20 millions
d'euros au cinéma et à l'audiovisuel un
investissement récompensé à Cann en 2016
avec le prix Caméra d'or pour divine les
mecs c'est comme les chiens s sentent
que tu as peur il te bouffe et toi tu as
souvent l'air d'avoir peur non j'ai pas
peur tu vois que tu as peur ben tu es
flippante aussi hein mais avant la
compétition le cinéma c'est avant tout
un échange avec les spectateurs cet été
pour la première fois la Région organise
des projections gratuites en plein air
sur quatre îles de loisirs dans les
Yvelines rendez-vous les 28 et 29
juillet à l'île loisir du valde Scine je
vous dirai du bout des lèvres je vous
aime du bout du
cœur